penicillin very big idea it was
discovered in the late 19th century by
Ernest to Chesney now he was a doctor in
the French army and when he was out on
his rounds he would be in the stables a
horse stables he noticed something
peculiar the horses would have sores
saddle sores on them but if the saddle
had a bunch of mold underneath it it
would actually heal those sores more
quickly and so we began to think well
maybe mold cures infections and so he
does some experiments he distills it he
puts it in a syringe injects it into a
bunch of disease guinea pigs and lo and
behold he cures them this is the
invention of penicillin but the tragic
problem was that Ernest Chesney was not
connected to any networks he was only 23
years old he was young a lowly soldier
in the army so when he wrote up these
findings very exciting findings he put
them in his PhD he sends them off to the
institut pasteur and they basically
ignore it because they don't know who he
is he's not connected to them they put
his PhD on the shelf and the secret of
penicillin dies it was not rediscovered
for 30 more years until someone else in
Scotland stumbled upon it and in those
30 years millions of people died of
infections it didn't need to die so as
Robert Merton knew when you connect
together multiples in a network big idea
has happened and when they're not
connected they can die